como Midia NINJA era ya una red organizada,
fue dedicarme a otro proyecto.
Se llama Fluxo, que en portugués significa "corriente".
Es un estudio periodístico en el centro de São Paulo,
donde experimento en directo
con lo que yo llamo los formatos post-TV.
También trato de encontrar nuevas maneras
de financiar el periodismo independiente
a través de una relación directa con el público,
con un público activo,
porque realmente quiero tratar de ganarme la vida
a base de mi propuesta.
Pero hay algo más importante aquí,
algo que creo que es más significativo y decisivo que mi ejemplo personal.
Dije que la transmisión en directo podía convertir
la red en una gigante cadena televisiva,
pero creo que puede hacer algo más,
porque después de ver que la gente la usa
no solo para informarse, sino para expresarse y organizarse políticamente,
puede convertir el ciberespacio en una arena política mundial
donde todo el mundo puede tener una voz,
una voz que le represente.
Porque la transmisión en vivo rompe el monopolio del discurso político,
el discurso literal del diálogo político
llevándolo más allá de la voz de unos pocos políticos y expertos
y dando poder al ciudadano a través de este poder directo e inmediato
de intercambio de experiencias y del diálogo,
les da poder para cuestionar e influir en las autoridades
de maneras que todavía están por ver.
Y creo que hace algo más, que es quizás aún más importante,
que puede combinar la simplicidad
de la tecnología con la objetividad y la subjetividad
de una manera muy política, tal como yo lo veo,
porque realmente ayuda a la audiencia,
al ciudadano, de ver el mundo a través de los ojos de otra persona,
por lo que ayuda al ciudadano a ponerse a sí mismo
en el lugar de otras personas.
Y esa idea, creo, debe ser la intención
y el propósito de un periodismo de calidad, el activismo justo
pero sobre todo, la política correcta.
Muchas gracias. Ha sido un honor.
(Aplausos)